NEXT, I WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO THE
FULTON COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
PAUL HOWARD JR. CHARGE FORMER
ATLANTA POLICE OFFICER GARRETT
ROTH WITH MURDER IN ADDITION TO
TEN OTHER CRIMINAL CHARGES.
IF CONVICTED, ROLFE FACES
POSSIBLE EXECUTION.
HE IS THIS ASPECT OF THE
SHOOTING OF RAYSHARD BROOKS.
LAST FRIDAY, FRIDAY, RAYSHARD
BROOKS PASSED OUT DRUNK IN THE
DRIVE-THROUGH LANE OF A WENDY’S
IN ATLANTA.
HIS CAR WAS BLOCKING TRAFFIC TO
RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES CALLED
POLICE.
THEY ARRIVED, WOKE BROOKS AND
ASKED HIM IF HE HAD BEEN
DRINKING.
BROOKS ADMITTED THAT HE HAD
BEEN.
OFFICERS THEN MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE TEXTBOOK DUI ARREST.
NOTHING UNUSUAL.
BUT THEN WHEN THEY TRIED TO TAKE
HIM INTO CUSTODY HAD STARTED
SWINGING.
HE SNATCHED A TASER FROM ONE OF
THEM AND TRIED TO USE IT FROM
OFFICER ROLFE’S.
WHEN HE RAISED THE TASER TO
FIRE, ROLF SHOT AND KILLED HIM.
HERE ARE OF THE VIDEO.
>> HEY SIR, ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> I’VE HAD SOME DRINKS TODAY.
IT MAY BE ONE AND A HALF.
I TOLD HER BABY, LET’S GO.
BECAUSE I’M HUNGRY.
>> WHAT KIND OF DRINKS DID YOU
HAVE?
>> I’M NOT SURE, SOMETHING SHE
ORDERED.
>> SO YOU’VE HAD ONE AND A HALF
DRINKS?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU’VE HAD TOO
MUCH TO DRINK TO BE DRIVING.
PUT YOUR HANDS BEHIND YOUR BACK
FOR ME.
PUT YOUR HANDS BADGER BACK.
>> STOP FIGHTING.
STOP FIGHTING.
YOU’RE GOING TO GET TASED.
>> TAKE OFF THE TASER.
TAKE OFF THE TASER.
>> STOP FIGHTING.
>> 63.
>> AFTER THE SHOOTING, OFFICER
ROLFE TRIED TO KEEP RAYSHARD
BROOKS ALIVE, HE TRIED TO
PERFORM CPR ON THE MAN HE JUST
SHOT.
>> KEEP BREATHING.
MR. BROOKS, KEEP BREATHING FOR
ME.
>> Tucker: NO MATTER HOW MUCH
YOU LOOK AT THESE VIDEOS OR HOW
CLOSELY IT’S A TRAGEDY OF EVERY
TIME.
THE QUESTION IS, WAS IT MURDER?
IF YOU SNATCHED A COPSE TASER
AND TRIED TO SHOOT THEM WITH IT,
MOST LIKELY YOU WOULD BE DEAD.
NO ONE WOULD MARCH IN YOUR
MEMORY AND NO ONE WOULD BURN A
BUILDING IN HER NAME.
NO ONE WILL CONSIDER YOUR DEATH
CONTROVERSIAL MUCH LESS A RACIAL
ACT.
BUT IN THIS CASE THINGS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT.
OFFICER ROLFE IS FACING THE
DEATH PENALTY.
THE MOB WANTS VENGEANCE NOW AND
THEY’VE EXPRESSED THAT BY
BURNING THE WENDY’S WHERE AHMAUD
ARBERY DIED TO THE GROUND.
THEY COMMITTED VIOLENCE.
WILL THEY COMMIT MORE IF HE’S
NOT CHARGED?
THAT HAS TO BE WEIGHING ON PAUL
HOWARD.
AND NOT JUST THAT, PAUL HOWARD
IS FIGHTING FOR HIS JOB.
HE’S FACING A RUNOFF ELECTION
SOON.
PAUL HOWARD HAS EVERY REASON TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT AND IS TO BOW
IMMEDIATELY FOR THE MOB’S
DEMANDS WHICH IS WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
DURING HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY, A MAN WHO WENT BERSERK ON
POLICE OFFICERS AND LOCKED INTO
THE GROUND AS "JOVIAL."
WATCH HOWARD STATEMENT HEARING
COMPARED TO THE VIDEO WE JUST
SHOWED YOU.
>> MR. BROOKS ON THE NIGHT OF
THE INCIDENT WAS CALM, HE WAS
CORDIAL, AND REALLY DISPLAYED AT
A COOPERATIVE NATURE.
SECONDLY, EVEN THOUGH MR. BROOKS
WAS SLIGHTLY IMPAIRED, HIS
DEMEANOR DURING THIS INCIDENT
WAS ALMOST JOVIAL.
>> JOVIAL.
YOU JUST WATCH THE TAPE.
CALM AND COOPERATIVE ARE
PROBABLY THE FIRST WORDS THAT
CAME TO MIND.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO, THE VERY
SAME PROSECUTOR, THE ONE YOU
JUST SAW, PAUL HOWARD, NOTED AT
A PRESS CONFERENCE A RECORDING
THAT A TASER IS CONSIDERED A
DEADLY WEAPON UNDER GEORGIA LAW.
WHATEVER, THAT WAS LAW.
IF IT WAS A TASER IT COULD HAVE
VERY EASILY HAVE BEEN OFFICER
ROLFE’S GUN.
HAD THAT BEEN THE CASE, OFFICER
ROLFE WOULD BE DEAD RIGHT NOW
AND YOU WOULD HAVE NEVER HEARD
THE STORY BECAUSE NO ONE IN THE
MEDIA WOULD HAVE DARED TELL YOU.
STILL THE PROSECUTOR’S
PROSECUTOR WOULD LIKE YOU TO
KNOW THAT MR. BROOKS WAS CORDIAL
AND NO THREAT AT ALL.
>> MR. BROOKS NEVER PRESENTED
HIMSELF AS A THREAT.
AT THE VERY BEGINNING HE WAS
PEACEFULLY SLEEPING IN HIS CAR.
>> JUST A GUY PEACEFULLY
SLEEPING IN HIS CAR AND NOW HE’S
DEAD.
SO WHY WERE THE COPS HASSLING A
MAN WHO WAS JUST PEACEFULLY
SLEEPING?
THE PROSECUTOR SUGGESTED WHY.
TAKE A GUESS?
>> OFFICER ROLFE ACTUALLY KICKED
MR. BROOKS LAID ON THE GROUND,
WHILE HE WAS THERE FIGHTING FOR
HIS LIFE.
OFFICER BRESLIN ACTUALLY STOOD
ON MR. BROOKS’ SHOULDER WHILE HE
WAS STRUGGLING FOR HIS LIFE.
THE MEAT DEMEANOR OF THE
OFFICERS IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
SHOOTING DID NOT REFLECT ANY
FEAR OR DANGER OF MR. BROOKS BUT
THEIR ACTIONS REALLY REFLECTED
OTHER KINDS OF EMOTIONS.
>> Tucker: OH, IT REFLECTED
GOT THAT?
WE KNOW WHAT’S COMING NEXT,
GUARANTEED.
THEY ARE GOING TO TELL TELL US
THIS IS A RACIALLY MOTIVATED
KILLING.
AND MAYBE THEY COULD PROVE IT.
BUT THERE IS ZERO EVIDENCE OF
THAT SO FAR.
IN THE ABSENCE OF EVIDENCE PAUL
HOWARD SHOULD NOT SAY THINGS
LIKE THIS AT PRESS CONFERENCES.
IT MAKES PEOPLE HATE EACH OTHER
AND HERE IS A COUNTRY APART
WHICH IS THE LAST THING WE NEED
RIGHT NOW.
ATLANTA’S POLICE DEPARTMENT’S
58% BLACK, THAT’S A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF BLACK PEOPLE THAN
THE CITY OF ATLANTA ITSELF.
SO EXPLAIN HOW SYSTEMIC RACISM
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SHOOTING.
AND SPEAK SLOWLY.
COPS IN ATLANTA KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THERE ARE REPORTS TONIGHT THAT
ANY OF THEM HAVE WALKED OFF THE
JOB AT THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
SHIFT.
NO DOUBT MANY OF THEM WILL
RETIRE FROM THE FOREST AND
LEAVE.
WHO WOULD ENFORCE THE LAW, YOU
MAKE LESS THAN A PLUMBER,
EVERYONE HATES YOU AND YOU COULD
EASILY GET KILLED.
NO WAY.
NO NORMAL PERSON WOULD WANT THAT
JOB.
SO WHO’S GOING TO TAKE THE JOB?
GOING FORWARD WE ARE GOING TO
GET A LOT OF PEOPLE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE IRONIES.
PRESSURE FROM THE NOT MOB WILL
NOT STOP POLICE BRUTALITY AND
THAT IS THE WORST KIND OF PEOPLE
THAT BECOME POLICE.
FOR NOW THOUGH ATTACKS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT BELIEVE THAT
MANY OF THEM HAVE NO POLICE
PROTECTION AT ALL.
RECENTLY THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
RIOTS CAME TO CHARLESTON,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
THIS HASN’T BEEN WIDELY REPORTED
BUT WITH THAT WE WOULD SHARE
WITH YOU.
THE A TRANSCRIPT OF A 911 CALL
AND THIS IS A QUOTE.
IT’S A MACINTOSH RESTAURANT, I
CALLED EARLIER BUT IT’S GOTTEN
WORSE.
THE RIOTS BROKE INTO THE
RESTAURANT AND THEY ARE STEALING
ALL THE MONEY COME ALL THE
ALCOHOL.
THEY ARE TEARING UP THE SEATS.
AND THERE ARE STILL NO COPS AND
30 PEOPLE IN DANGER.
NO EVIDENCE THAT THE COPS EVER
CAME.
KEN SNYDER OWNS A WINE BAR, AND
HE SAID, IT’S TOO LATE, MY PLACE
IS DESTROYED.
SCHNEIDER LAID THEN LATER SAID
HE WAS COME IN COMPLETELY IN
DISBELIEF THAT NO ONE CAME.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING MORE THAN JUST
THEIR BUSINESSES IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
A NEW YORK CITY MERGERS ARE UP
25% JUST THIS YEAR AND THAT’S
DESPITE THE LOCKDOWNS.
IN JUST THE PAST MONTH THE
NUMBER OF MURDERS RECORDED IN
THE CITY HAS LITERALLY DOUBLED
COMPARED TO A YEAR AGO.
WHEN HE POLITICIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT, INNOCENT PEOPLE
INEVITABLY DIED.
THAT IS NOT A PARTISAN POINT.
THE EXPECTATION THAT THE POLICE
WILL COME AND PROTECT YOU IS NOT
IDEOLOGICAL.
ASK ANY LIBERAL WHO’S EVER
CALLED THE POLICE IN CRISIS AND
HAD THEM NOT SHOW UP.
IT’S TERRIFYING NO MATTER WHO
YOU VOTE FOR.
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM
CRIMINALS IS NOT SOME FEATURE OF
GOVERNMENT WE HOPE FOR, IT’S WHY
WE HAVE GOVERNMENT AND THE WHOLE
POINT OF GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS NO REASON TO HAVE
GOVERNMENT OTHERWISE.
AND PROBABLY WOULDN’T PAY THE
BILL.
AND TAXATION WITHOUT PROTECTION
IS JUST THAT.
AND THEY DISTRACT YOU AND TO
CONFUSE YOU FOR SLOGANS OR
RIOTING.
THAT’S MUCH LARGER, AND THEY
TREAT ALL AMERICAN CITIZENS
EQUALLY REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE